algunos pares ordenados para la función
lineal x se dan en la tabla de a
continuación que ecuación se utilizó
para generar esta tabla y bueno si te
das cuenta que tenemos un montón de
puntos los cuales son puntos de esta
función lineal es decir cuando x vale 1
entonces lleva el de 11 cuando x vale 2
10 vales 16 y así todos los demás y
bueno de todas estas rectas que tengo
aquí una de ellas va a ser la recta que
me va a generar todos los puntos que
tengo aquí en esta tabla
así que intentemos probar con el primer
punto cuando x vale 1 y vale 11 y bueno
vamos ecuación por ecuación para ver
cuál de éstas es la que representa estos
puntos
a ver si x vale 1 entonces bien vale 11
que pasa es que aquí sustituyó a x por
uno me quedaría 4 que multiplica a 1
esto
1 y bueno 4 por 1 más 1
esto es lo mismo que 5 eso quiere decir
que en esta recta cuando x vale 1 vale 5
111 por lo tanto podemos cancelar esta
opción porque date cuenta que no
llegamos al valor de 11 que nos dice la
tabla para la ecuación que sea la
respuesta de esta función lineal tiene
que generar todos estos valores de la
tabla
es decir que dado cualquier valor que le
meta de x de esta tabla me debe de
generar su correspondiente y que está
también aquí bien ahora intentemos para
la segunda ecuación y es igual a 3 x + 8
cuando x vale 1
entonces me quedaría tres por uno lo
cual es tres más ocho lo cual es 11
parece ser que si funciona ahora vamos a
intentar con el segundo punto para ver
si también funciona cuando x vale dos
hits debe de valer 16 y aquí que me
quedarían y me quedaría 3 por 2
ok más
y bueno 3 por 2 668 14 y no me da 16 por
lo tanto aquí cuando x vale 2 10 vale 14
lo cual no es 16 y por lo tanto está
parecía ser una buena candidata para
hacer nuestra respuesta
sin embargo date cuenta que cuando x
vale 2 ya no vale 16 por lo tanto no es
nuestra respuesta ok pues es hora de
intentar con la tercera y es igual a 5 x
6 y bueno qué pasa si sustituimos el
valor de x por uno me quedaría cinco por
uno lo cuales 56 es 11 de lujo hasta
aquí vamos bien ahora vamos a probar con
el valor de 2 si x vale 2
entonces me va a quedar 5 por 2 lo cual
es 10 10 + 6 perfecto es 16 y en este
momento creo que está me parece una
candidata que suena bastante bien esta
ocasión es una candidata que me está
sonando a que es la respuesta y es que
es más ya podríamos concluir que todos
los demás puntos
si están generados por esta recta porque
si nosotros decimos que dos de estos
puntos nos generan esta ecuación
entonces los otros dos también van a ser
generados por esta ecuación y cómo puedo
saber eso bueno porque recuerda que dos
puntos definen una recta pero de todas
maneras vamos a corroborar con estos
otros dos puntos para ver si llegamos a
que está en efecto es muy solución que
pasa cuando x vale 7 bueno cuando x vale
7 me queda 5 por 7 5 por 7 35 35 6 de
lujo es 41 y que pasan cuando x vale 9
cuando x vale 9 bueno pues me quedaría 5
x 9 lo cual es 45 45 6 lo cual es 51 y
de lujo es justo lo que tenemos aquí por
lo tanto esta es la respuesta correcta
de este ejercicio ya no es necesario
fijarnos en las demás porque ésta es la
que cumple todos estos puntos y por lo
tanto es la respuesta de este problema
es decir que esta ecuación
a 5 x 6 metas los valores de esta tabla
me genera esta tabla es decir cuando x
vale 1 vale 11 cuando x baleados lleva
16 cuando x vale 7 lleva de 41 y cuando
ex vale 9 10 vale 51